winkler
[Musik]
am kamin
polanski
kostja ullmann ist hat meist bekommen
und
wir wollen
ja ich übersetze mal kurzerhand es wurde
jetzt gerade schon etwas emotional eving
hat uns gerade erklärt dass er vom irak
nach ankara also in die türkei von der
türkei nach belarus von dort aus
geflogen ist und daneben den weg
gegangen ist über polen nach deutschland
er wurde jetzt gerade sehr emotional
weil er sagte in polen hat man ihn wohl
auch verletzt sie haben ihn dort
nicht gut behandelt er sagte es sei sehr
unmenschlich oder unmenschliche zustände
seien vor ort
gewesen und dass er hier in deutschland
hoffnung hat dass die menschen hier in
deutschland gute menschen sind nette
menschen sind
und hier natürlich die hoffnung schöpft
auch hier bleiben zu können
what happens
willi musiker wie kosten her ja ich
übersetze noch einmal kurzerhand reding
hat uns gerade erzählt dass er selbst
nicht
physisch verletzt wurde seelisch jedoch
seine freunde wurden geschlagen man hat
ihr ihnen schnitte an den armen
verpasste auch hat man ihn
elektroschocks gegeben diese bunten
sitzen natürlich auch bei regen sehr
sehr tief er sagt uns auch dass er sich
hier endlich wie ein mensch fühlt in
polen und in belarus hat man ihn nicht
wie einen menschen
behandelt und deshalb ist er sehr froh
hier in deutschland zu sein trotzdem ist
natürlich jetzt erstmal dieser
erstaufnahmeeinrichtung und ich möchte
ihnen noch einmal fragen wie die
situation hier vor ort ist den teller so
gern haus der situation hier in des
rapide camp
hier in das camp
also regen scheint erstmal soweit
zufrieden zu sein hier in dieser
erstaufnahmeeinrichtung er sagt dass er
jeden tag hier essen bekommt dass er
hier auch natürlich einen sicheren
schlafplatz hat und dass die menschen
hier wohl sehr nett zu ihm sein trotzdem
muss ich nun einmal auch noch hinzufügen
wir konnten eben beobachten wie helfer
einen rucksack mit warmer kleidung über
den zaun werfen
weil natürlich auch es auch hier sehr
kalt werden kann diese container können
glaube ich auch nur begrenzt geheizt
werden deshalb ist auch hier noch einen
großen bedarf an hilfe
gibt und damit möchte ich einmal zu euch
zurück